[Music]
fans had been waiting for what felt like
an eternity for a wonder woman movie so
when it finally arrived it was a
worldwide phenomenon that made gal gadot
a superstar and set a new standard for
dc's movie universe
needless to say kids loved it but when
they watched it with their parents the
adults in the room latch on to a few
things that children might not pick up
on
from the quirks of themschiran society
to chris pine's love of a certain mode
of transport
here are the things that only adults
notice in wonder woman
secrets and wars before it dives into an
adventure set against the backdrop of
world war one
the film opens with diana receiving a
package from bruce wayne containing a
photo which proved to him that diana had
been around
looking exactly the same for decades
bruce tracked the original down and sent
it to diana as a gesture of friendship
to help her keep her secret
and we later learned the photo was taken
in the village of veld after diana steve
and their compatriots
liberated the town from german soldiers
and apparently passed into history later
without anyone ever taking too much
notice
but let's unpack this for a moment a
photographer captured this image
featuring a lady with a glowing rope
who'd just taken an entire town back
from the germans
and then it just went away no one
followed up no one ever asked the
photographer what was up with the
literal amazon hanging out with soldiers
well maybe someone did there are plenty
of legends of supernatural events
occurring during world war one
including tales of angelic figures who
helped defend the belgian city of mons
diana certainly fits the bill of an
angelic figure who showed up to help
soldiers so maybe she was just written
off as a legend who happened to have her
picture taken
selective understanding the film's
greatest source of comedy is the culture
clash that ensues as steve trevor tries
to introduce diana to modern life in
1917 and her difficulty understanding it
not that we can blame her things get
pretty complicated when steve has to
explain the legal concept of a marriage
that's permanent
until it isn't for instance then why do
they do it
i have no idea if marriage is that
difficult to understand though
it stands to reason that she's going to
have a hard time with the rest of the
world
diana stays in our world after the
events of the movie which means
she suddenly has to learn about
everything from banking to home
ownership
imagine the conversation that ensues the
first time someone has to explain
bankruptcy or parking tickets to her of
course if the film stopped to
acknowledge every single explanation
that steve and etta had to offer
ares probably would have conquered the
world without much trouble there are a
few other examples that are pretty
notable however
what's that it's a uh
oh on the boat from themyscira diana
makes it clear that she has an
understanding of reproduction but is
puzzled by the sight of a couple holding
hands
the mysqra is rich in art and culture
but diana doesn't seem to understand the
purpose of clothes that exist for
anything other than fighting
she views ice cream as a true miracle
yet has no trouble with the concept of a
camera bullets and bracelets
it's established pretty early on that
wonder woman has powers other amazon
warriors do not
and by the end of the movie we know why
diana isn't just an amazon she's a
demigod the daughter of zeus and
hippolyta giving her powers far beyond
the warrior prowess of a typical amazon
these powers apparently include jumping
to incredible heights supernatural
toughness and super strength
we see her do things like walking out of
a collapsing tower unscathed
and tossing around armored vehicles on
more than one occasion yet whenever
anyone fires a gun at her
she deflects it either with her
bracelets or with her shield if diana
can walk away from being tossed around
by the literal god of war
there's a good chance bullets won't do
much against her but the film never
shows us that
in the comics it's mentioned that she's
so skilled that she can control where
they ricochet but in the movie we're
guessing it's because deflecting slow-mo
bullets just looks really cool
there's another reason though at the
beginning of the film she watches all of
her amazon sisters die in a hail of
gunfire
maybe it's not that diana can't survive
bullets but just that she doesn't want
to try
motorcycle madness if you go to see a
movie starring chris pine chances are
pretty good that you're going to see him
on a motorcycle
he even rode one in the distant future
of the star trek films including the one
in which he had to find a motorcycle on
an alien planet
if disney had let him he probably would
have done it into the woods too
world war one makes for a much easier
place to find a motorcycle than the 24th
century but it still feels a little
shoehorned in
after diana and steve head to the
village of veld on horses to investigate
dr poison's chemical weapons diana flies
into a rage and hops back on her horse
to pursue ludendorff
steve gets to the village moments after
diana but instead of mounting up to join
her he spends a few moments looking for
a motorcycle instead
even though his horse is still standing
right there maybe steve only rides
horses at the last resort or maybe
pine wanted to look cool on a motorcycle
again and honestly can you blame him
sharp dressed when etta candy and steve
trevor first try to dress diana in
modern clothes
steve slips a pair of glasses on her and
edna makes a pretty obvious observation
about that disguise
suddenly she's not the most beautiful
woman you've ever seen glasses or no
diana stands out in a crowd
and when she and steve infiltrate a
german party it's understandably
difficult for anyone in the crowd to
take their eyes off of her
her goal is to kill ludendorff and she
aims to do so by stuffing her sword down
the back of her dress until it's time
for some stabbing
it's a great visual but it doesn't quite
hold up if you take a minute to think
about it with the number of people
taking second looks at diana as she
walks past
someone probably should have noticed she
was carrying a giant piece of magic
metal could they have seen the hilt of
the sword and simply thought it was
elaborate jewelry
sure but ludendorff probably should have
noticed something was up when he
literally put his hands on it
leftover weapons diana spends the film
convinced that all she has to do to stop
the war is kill ares but steve has a
different mission
his goal is the same but he's going
after general ludendorff and dr poison
who have manufactured extremely powerful
chemical
weapons the evil doctor didn't just make
the poison gas that will kill
untold numbers of people if it's
unleashed on the world though she also
granted ludendorff incredible strength
and durability which almost makes him
diana's equal in combat
almost at the end of the film aerys
tries to get diana to kill dr poison who
he considers the ultimate example of
humanity's corruption
diana spares her but her lab is
destroyed by steve and his team
and the poison gas is neutralized when
steve sacrifices his life to blow it all
up it all seems like a pretty tidy
ending
except that we know dr poison worked in
multiple places to perfect her formula
research like this tends to involve a
lot of documentation and it makes sense
that she'd even have earlier slightly
less deadly versions of both the poison
and the strength enhancer that we never
saw
even assuming she never made a chemical
weapon again after diana spared her
it's not hard to imagine dr poison's
creations or the science behind them
falling into the hands of the nazis just
a few years later
gods and monsters the film's climactic
showdown between diana and ares reveals
a twist
aries was not ludendorf as diana had
assumed but was actually sir patrick
morgan who's been manipulating events
for ages in order to give humanity the
right machines of war to destroy
themselves
in a battle with the unmasked ares the
god of war seems to have telekinetic
command over just about everything in
sight he uses that to fashion himself
some fierce looking
comic accurate scrap metal armor and
hurls shards of airplanes and tanks that
are heroin
those are very cool things for him to do
but as the battle progresses he reaches
into the skies and
summons lightning bolts the movie can
give its gods whatever powers it wants
but isn't lightning zeus's thing and
don't we know that because we see him
using it in a flashback in this very
same film
why does the power that ares has over
weapons of war
which makes perfect sense suddenly
extend to lightning
sure it definitely looks cool but
viewers with a very basic understanding
of mythology might have a hard time
figuring that one out